welcome back everyone
we have another recap video this is my
round three game from the reykjavik open
and i actually want to start by showing
my preparation from this game
uh i was playing video master michael
dordery
from
canada
doherty daughtery
apologies for maybe butchering the
pronunciation
but uh this was a an older player who i
found games dating back
for the past couple decades
and
before the game i spent a few hours
trying to
just be really well prepared
against the sidelines that he plays
and i'm going to start by showing my
prep file for this game
i'll switch scenes here so we see uh the
study i initially prepared this in chess
base but i brought in the pgn to le
chess
so the the couple hours leading up to
the game i was reviewing
basically all the potential
lines i could be expecting based on what
he's played in the past
and uh i do want to show just a couple
like interesting trappy lines i was
preparing
uh i decided to to start with d4
and one potential variation that he
could play
actually like the main thing is in his
repertoire
is a pterodactyl opening which is
starting with this move c5
and this is a line i actually covered in
a st louis
chess club lecture from a different move
order actually from the sicilian move
order with knight c3 on move two
but essentially it transposes and
there's a really cool line here for
white
that he's had a few games here in the
past after queen a5 bishop d2
black wins back the pawn
and then a really
venomous move from white knight d5
uh with the idea to play bishop b4 and
harass the queen and also tie down the
queen to defending c7
and if black's not careful here if we
imagine a move like knight f6 there's
bishop e4 queen c6 and bishop b5
and surprisingly
the black queen is trapped in this
position
uh because if queendix b5 or queen e6
only two safe looking squares there's
knight c7 with the amazing fork
so i was looking a bit deeper here like
he's had games with b6 and there should
be four
and i was planning to go into this line
which stockfish already gives as a very
big plus for white
and my preparation even went a little
bit further
where i'm just kind of getting a sense
of the
the tactical ideas queen g3 preparing
knight c7
so anyway i don't want to go too deep
down the rabbit hole of my preparation
but i am leaving this in a publicly
chest study so if people want to analyze
further you can click the link in the
video description and see all the the
fun
tricky lines i prepared for this game
which didn't actually happen in the game
so let's actually get to the game
because uh
it turns out that i i was surprised as
early as move three i played d4
g6
e4 bishop g7 knight c3
and i got excited here because my
opponent reached for a c pawn
i was expecting pawn c5
but he played the move pawn c6
and uh i was out of my
pre-game preparation but i did have a
sense of uh of what to do in this
position now i should note this was not
a line i was expecting i found no
previous games from him in the database
in this line
but this was a line i prepared
vaguely for hikaru
after hikaru played this against me in
some online blitz game may have been a
few online blitz games
this is one of hikaru's kind of pet
opening lines
and i went ahead here and played the
move knight f3
and after d5 i played the move h3
now i'm realizing that i'm leaking all
the notation analysis here
um i think i'm going to switch back the
scene to just a larger board so i'm not
leaking anything
if people have a preference like what
layout i should use
voice your opinion in the comments
because i do want to cater to what
people prefer but again i'm going to
leave all my analysis in the leachat
study so people are welcome to
just kind of go through at their own
pace
and yeah watch the video as they go as
well
but uh getting back to this position
the point of playing h3 is to prevent
the lightsword bishop from developing
actively and i'm trying to create a
situation here where this bishop doesn't
have a great home
for example if black takes and this is
actually what happened the game
takes
it's a little bit awkward for black to
develop the bishop to f5 because there's
knight g3
and uh there's cases where i can get
like a favorable position where i either
get the bishop pair or the bishop has to
retreat back to
a really passive square
so my opponent here played knight to d7
which is a common idea the the point is
to play knight f6 uh trail the pair of
knights and get this knight to f6
but
i respond with bishop to c4
and already black has to be really
careful about potential tactics
against f7 pawn
and uh
the natural looking move here is knight
g f6
to just challenge the knight but then
this would walk into some funny lines
and i was calculating this during the
game and i'm not sure if i'd actually go
for this but there's a funny line
knight eg5
hitting f7
and if black plays a move
like e6
then
already knight takes f7 uh is looking
really deadly because king takes f7
knight g5
king moves somewhere king can't move to
f8 because knight takes e6 if king e8s
again knight takes e6
and white's getting just a ton of attack
for uh for sacking the piece
and uh stockfish is already giving a
winning advantage for white here
so long story short this would be
dangerous to enter also if castling then
there's potential to
take on f7 and then knight g5
and it's kind of a headache for black to
just allow these lines
so instead of my opponent playing knight
gf6
my opponent played the funny looking
move
knight df6
with the same intention of trading the
knights and just eventually getting the
knight to f6 but in this case i can just
avoid the trade entirely i played the
move knight g3
which actually turns out to be a novelty
uh this move has never been played
before
but it's very logical because the point
is i'm i'm just leaving black's knight
in the way of the other knights
and in chess we call this superfluous
knights where the knights kind of
defend each other but they also get in
the way of each other
and now the only way for black to
develop the latin g8 is to
go to the edge
and this is what happened and this move
is still
very much playable because idea is not a
5.
and
i really wanted to punish this move
somehow but
i didn't find any way to create like any
immediate threats and i decided to
just
kind of slow play on c3
which this structure it's very nice to
have against the opponent's fiance
because it does in some sense undermine
the bishop
and the other reason why i played c3 was
a prophylactic move
i was trying to prevent
knight f5 because obviously this is
black's main intention this trades to
minor pieces
uh but if black goes for another five
here
then there's idea to take and after
bishop takes off five queen b3
would hit uh both
pawns which are just not sufficiently
defended here
yeah so c3 tricky move but here my
opponent castled
i played 95 i was still trying to be
prophylactic still trying to pressure f7
and again i have the same idea if knight
f5 i would take
bishop take and queen b3 hitting both
pawns
and yeah white's just winning upon here
so
um yeah i'm setting up some landmines
but my opponent wasn't blundering so
easily
and here knight d5 is played which i
think is a very reasonable square for
the knight just blocking the bishop
and the d5 square is like one of the
nice center squares that black has under
under good control
so here game continued very simple moves
clean development castling another five
take and take
so essentially black got what he wanted
is the trade of knights and finally
developed the bishop
but um the position is still really
comfortable for whites
and i thought the
next several moves are like very
intuitive and natural just kind of
improving the pieces that have yet to
enter the game
and i didn't spend too much time
thinking in this position because just
might as well play an active improving
move queen f3
uh here we see queen d6 rookie one
rookie eight
and
now it was a matter of trying to find
some sort of plan in the position like
i've improved my queen improved my rook
it is a question where my bishop should
develop to because bishop d2 doesn't
look so enticing i don't want to put it
to e3 rf4 and allow trades
and g5 would just probably ask to get
forked so i found a move here
with uh just a simple plan of
trying to expand my center pawns
and i should note here that white has a
slight advantage because i i control a
bit more space with the center pawn on
d4
and sometimes when you have a small
space advantage like this
one of the typical plans is to try and
increase the space advantage
and i played the move here bishop to b3
just preparing to grab more space with
the ventral pawn c4
and here my appointment played a funny
move
bishop to c8
and i'll just show my annotation briefly
here
i said lol but what else to do for black
it was actually a bit difficult for
black to
bind
any active plan
uh like the rooks are are standing
behind the pawns black would love to
expand
but it's really difficult to do so and
f6 doesn't look so attractive so i think
bishop c8 was kind of just a waiting
move
and here i happily
play c4 grab some space
forcing the knight backwards
i should note knight b6 just walks into
a fork
so knight
retreats back to f6
and now i complete development now that
knight's no longer hitting the e3 square
um
my pieces are finding even more
happiness
and
again my opponent played a funny looking
move bishop f5 just
undoing the previous move
but uh yeah again just kind of waiting
and sometimes
it's still tricky to
make progress in these positions because
even though my setup is really nice
black's position is a hard nut to crack
and my strategy here is to just keep
gradually improving and
generally if i can fully optimize my
pieces
that's what will lead to tactics so i
improved my worst place piece here with
rook ad1
opponent played knight d7
and i didn't want to trade the knights
even though this is a very playable move
i decided to play knight g4
keeping some pressure
and now i have ideas of knight h6
so if lock's not careful here and just
plays like a nothing move then knight h6
is winning material because black either
has to take
and allow the rook to get trapped
or after king h8 then i win material on
f5
so uh my opponent fought for a bit and
took on g4
i took back with the pawn
um so even though we traded and
generally trades do favor the side that
has less space i didn't mind the trade
because now i have the bishop pair and
i've also in some sense strengthened my
kingside setup there's ideas now of g3
king g2 rook h1
and later attacking on the file and one
one thing i do want to point out about
pawns this is kind of an obvious thing
but
not everyone has made this realization
is that pawns on the h or a files
are half as powerful as pawns on
the b through g files and the reason for
that is a pawn
on each file only controls
one square
pawn in this case on the g file controls
two swirls
so that definitely like crossed my mind
at some point is that my pawn is a
little bit happier towards the center
but here game continued queen c7
i attacked the queen with bishop f4
queen b6
and
here i played a move which
uh was a bit tricky i i spent a long
time trying to to figure out whether it
was worth playing c5
but i didn't want to give black just an
easy decision like to move the queen and
then
then the ball is back in my court and i
have to figure out what to do
so i played a more non-chemical move
here
queen g3
and this sets up a few landmines in the
position
um first of all i create the battery
with my queen and bishop so there's
already some ideas of
bishop c7 and there are cases where the
queen could
could more easily get trapped if i do
get this move in bishop c7 in
combination with c5 but surprisingly my
opponent
uh just cracked here and play the move
which gave me a very strong tactic
uh here my opponent played pawn c5
and my opponent actually told me after
the game
that right after he
released his hand from playing ponzi 5
he realized
what is coming next
and
after my next move
my opponent just resigned so there's a
very strong
tactical blow in this position
if you don't see it already feel free to
pause the video
and figure out white to move
make black resign but the move is to
exploit
this now more
exploitable diagonal
and play the move bishop a4
and uh very quickly saw this this was
actually one of the
the points of playing queen g3 i was
waiting for black to play the move c5
and my dream came true
and the reason why this is so powerful
is that i'm simply hitting the knight
the knight is pinned to the rook
and there's no easy way to resolve the
pin uh there's very few ways to defend
the knight if rook d8
then i have bishop c7 with the fork
and if queen d8
then black is just a uh
a sitting duck a sad turtle
i would just take on c5
unleashing yet another pin so here the
knight is pinned in two directions
and white is winning
a bolo of material coming up
so
yeah that was pretty much the game
overall i think it was a smooth game uh
kind of goes to show one of the
strategies is when you have a slightly
better position
sometimes it just requires patience
and gradual improving moves
and i was fortunate that my opponents
just kind of cracked early
allowing the tactic
here the engine gives a5 for black
and then there's no immediate tactical
blow and the game would go on
one possible continuation is c5 queen a6
a4
where white still enjoys kind of a very
healthy position more space two bishops
i would have good chances but it would
still be a fight
so
that does it for this recap i hope you
guys enjoyed it thanks again for your
patience with the recap videos
uh when i got back from iceland my
macbook pro stopped working and i went
through
the whole uh
uh kind of troubleshooting with the
apple store eventually got it back
functional and that's why i used to edit
all my videos and thumbnails so stay
tuned for more recap videos if you have
questions or feedback leave them in the
comments below and i'll see you guys in
the next video